Vô tư phát của công bố sơ thầm định dự thảo nghị định về một số chế độ phụ cấp đặc thủ đối với công chức.
Vình chức người là động vào lực lượng vũ trang trong cơ sở i tế công lập phụ cấp trong dịch.
Hỗ trợ nhân viên i tế thôn, tổ rân phố và cố đỡ thôn, bản ró bộ i tế xây dự.
Dự thảo quy định người đứng đầu cơ sở khám, chữa bánh quy định mù sĩ khá kép, làm thêm dự.
Chứ hợp thiếu như lực thì mù sĩ trực hai mê tư trên hai mê tư dự.
Mước phụ cấp chức hai mê tư trên hai mê tư dự.
Bà chăm hai mê lâm nghị đồng một phíng cho hạm đặc biệt.
Hạm một hai chăm năm mê lâm nghị đồng cho hạm hai và đơn vị pháp í.
Kỹ thuật hình sự liên quan, một chăm tả mê lâm nghị đồng cho cơ sở còn lại và cấp hiệu ngoại vệ.
Mày mê nghịnh đồng cho chạm í tế xả và đơn vị tư tự.
Phụ cấp chức thường chú ngoại vệ tự ứng một chăm sống mê nghị.
Một chăm hai mê lâm nghịnh, chi Minh nghịn, ba mê lâm nghịnh đồng một phíng.
Người trực hai mê tư trên hai mê tư dự hỗ trợ tiền ăn bố mấy nghịnh đồng một phíng.
Được nghị bụ thăm mức một ngày, ngày thường, ngày nhỉ, hoặc hai ngày, tế, tế,
lâm thím dự, lâm đêm được chả lương theo quy định pháp lợt lào động.